welcome
I'm Reinhold Martin the director of the
Buell Center those of you who have not
yet had a chance to participate in the
dialogues that we have collaborated with
with Enrique this summer and here I'm
only here basically to get out of the
way and offer the platform to our two
very distinguished colleagues who have
been conducting this conversation now
for seven years and and in each case
around a different theme so I first want
to sort of paradoxically welcome Dean
Markley to his own stage and I think
also one of mine those are your new the
school that I'm sure you know that you
have an opportunity to to learn from
Marc and a wonderful lecture course that
he does I guess coming up in the fall
again and and and of course Peter
Eisenman architect educator theorist of
Yale University those interventions
provocations and contributions you
surely also know so the the theme agreed
upon today is is simply the word design
we'll see where that goes and you know
ask the rules of game I should say the
format is is strictly sort of controlled
one hour of give-and-take and then one
hour of questions from you so prepare
your questions okay thank you again and
welcome
sorry I have to say sorry sorry I can
say happy birthday to people and he
ruined my opening line first of all
thank you
mark and I have a bet that we had agreed
when we started to do ten ten of these
to correspond to his deanship and Mark
said he didn't know if he'd be able to
finish because he wasn't sure that he
wanted to be Dean for 10 years and I
said no no you have to do this so our
bed is that he he says I doubt we'll
forget 210 I said well I'll bet we go
over 10 I kind of over under around 10
so if he we do it for 10 years nobody
wins we do it for 9 you win if we do it
for 11 there's a big meal four seasons
yeah four seasons for four but the rule
is if it's ten nobody wins
do it because because I neelu's no but
you could cancel the 11:00 sure we have
to we'll discuss it over lunch anyway
that was not my I wanted to say
something much more avuncular and
sentimental to introduce which is not
usually my role but I have to say that
in addition to it being my birthday and
therefore I'm in a rather sort of funny
mood I don't like birthdays but what is
even funnier is that this friday marks
the fiftieth anniversary of the last
exam that I took at Columbia University
in summer school I was trying to qualify
for my Fulbright scholarship which I had
won and so I needed a second language
and had to take French because I was
going to France and I took an eight-week
eight hour a day immersion course in
French and so Friday is the key day and
fifty years ago I was where you all are
so how dumb I was just so that you will
know not how dumb am i but how i dumb I
was was in my years at Columbia I never
knew Rudolf it over north studied with
him and I took quite a number of courses
in scorn and
I was innocent of Rudolf it cover which
tells you that there's meant much hope
for all of you who think that you know
something when you really know very
little in fact I was going to France on
a mission from Professor Robert Brenner
of the art history department who is a
famous goth assist I was one of his pet
students and I was going to study the
4th nave bay at soir song Cathedral to
find out how why it was different than
all the other bays and so I saw if you
could believe it that was my Fulbright
grant and of course what happened to me
which is apocryphal I went over on the
SS flan I spoke French the whole way
over
I saw the movie plan de soleil on them
which was with Alain Delon the first in
French and I was really into it and I
took the boat boat train from love with
to the God to Noah I got out of the
garden Noah I got into a taxi and I even
remember the instructions I said as
you've ship with Layla Sheila Kuehl si
vous play and the taxi driver looked at
me turned around looked at me said hey
buddy better if you speak English and I
thought that's it because I had also at
the same time I had a Kenney grant to go
to England and I had decided to go to
France and I got back on the next train
and went to Cambridge and that's how you
and I happen to be here today anyway
I mean that the the the way this works
is normally Peter is the sort of leadoff
hitter and he fills a room with wisdom
I'm feeling unwise and then we discuss
how how wise he has been and it seems to
me that in the end always what we're
trying to talk about is what's cooking
right not just for us but for in the
field so this 50-year thing seems to me
looms you know so it could be sort of
like given what happened in the last 50
years what might be happening now but
the theme the actual word we're going to
concentrate on so we'll probably look at
what this word design might has made and
what it might mean in the future we're
going to consecrate a design so it's
going to start with a question from me
to you right which is architecture and
design what's the relationship yeah well
I I want to say just to preface before I
answer that question what we are both
asking in discussing this is has design
gone anywhere in 50 years in other words
could it have been predicted where it
was and where it is today and we can
argue that I would say this that
certainly Rhino was saying earlier you
know European design was in an
ascendancy in the late 50s and early 60s
I was looking at a book of an Italian
architect kaca Domini
who is obscure died an architect I
should tell you
not in preparation this but just
yesterday we were because we're doing an
apartment block in Milan and we're
trying to understand the typology of
apartment blocks and kaca domine was one
of the favorite Neo Liberty
you know post-war guys who was doing
upper middle-class Milanese apartments
and it seems to me that design has its
ascendancy and and so you look at what
cacio Domini was doing I mean he was
doing furniture or furniture he was
doing lamps he was doing knives forks
and spoons I mean he was designing
everything for the arising out
bourgeoisie of noir you know recovering
northern Italy you know where the
residue of the auto industry from Torino
was you know turning Milan into a
fashion capital in a design world Domus
under joe ponte what had always been
interested in in design but it seemed to
be in in an ascendancy Casabella which
retained its name you know beautiful
house under Rodgers in the 50s and 60s
so I would argue that the capital of the
world of design if we just want to place
the world certainly was northern Italy
and certainly Milano
it certainly wasn't Paris or London in
the I mean London doesn't come into the
scene
you know it had this is tomorrow
exhibition and things but basically
design you know London was still you
couldn't eat a good meal in England
women still where you know with those
strange hairdos Soho was in a certain
kind of ascendancy but Milan the
difference between Milan and London that
I experienced was quite something and
what you realize is even the minor
architects were into design all right
and of course what I would argue is that
design is that manifestation of the
ascendancy of global capital is the mark
of that ascendancy
I wasn't saying good or bad but that
every you know you had to go and have
things designed when I was working at
the architects collaborator for Gropius
in Cambridge they owned a shop called
design research which was right next
door which Ben Thompson who became Dean
at Harvard ran and Swiss Swedish design
Marimekko was the rage you know and cool
aesthetic you know slimmed down
simple aesthetics as opposed to the
Milanese which was far more baroque and
in its in its attitude so but-but-but
Marimekko and and and dr was you know
everything in your house had to be dr
you know white dishes white plates you
know and so the question is there was
the same culture of design that we have
in a certain way maybe less available to
target the market of the target stores
but i think what is really interesting
and why i'm interested in the subject is
first of all harvard has several times
change the name of its school it's no
longer the GSD but it is one of the few
schools that goes by the name of design
school and it changed that i believe in
the 40s i believe that's when the the
GSD changed its name and the provocation
for me to be interested in this subject
today is that cornell after being one of
the i think the second or third oldest
architecture schools is deciding to
change their name from college of
architecture to college of design to as
its sense operate more efficiently in a
more comprehensive idea of design as you
know systems analysis environmental
analysis etc going into other areas
other than architecture as a major focus
and of course one argues is that the the
ascendancy of design as an idea as an
overriding idea as opposed to i think
architecture which stands
something else and I think that if the
name if words are important then
architecture has always been other than
in addition to design something other
and other than or in addition to other
than others which one do you want
I'll talk take them both for to start
with all right so we can look at both of
them I would argue that design
ultimately what do we mean by design
well certainly better function in in one
one sense in other words that is an
overall strategic view of the world a
process and its tactics I would argue
this the tactics of design if design is
a strategic discourse let's say would be
aesthetics
the major tactic would be certainly even
to the sacrificing of function I mean if
you look at any of the things that don't
mignon catch Adam and yoni was doing in
terms of knives forks and spoons you'd
say oh god you know can you get food on
to those things and the lamps and the
chairs that he was making you say you
know and still we can go back as early
as the Bauhaus and say you know the
aestheticization that is the modern
aesthetic was always the component I
think first before function let's say I
think that Mises chairs corbs chairs
Rietveld chairs sacrificed comfort let's
say or function for an aesthetic value
let's say given to the product and I
mean I sit on tone' chairs we have them
all over our house from the first decade
of this century
they ain't comfortable but they look
nice
you know the bentwood has a certain
quality the the cane the caning has a
certain quality etc so I would argue
that designs ultimate goal within in the
20th century was had something to do
with an aesthetic of the modern and I
would say that architecture if I to go
back to its its particular autonomy is a
is a formal one
not an aesthetic one and I and I think
that for me is an enormous difference
that is an internal logic and
consistency that subsumes design or
aesthetic not design let's say but the
aesthetic within its internal logic so
the so the punchline is that if a school
of the school of architecture changes
its name to a school of design from your
point of view it's a retrograde act on
the one hand because it's a return to a
kind of our house I would I would argue
would not only return to that but it's
it's a return to the Isetta cessation of
products let's say and you are a
designer I would argue that I've never
designed anything then I live in a dumb
house dumb apartment where dumb clothes
so this the stupidity that you had when
you graduated from Columbia is a huge as
a huge yes as an architect but but some
people would argue but you've done
plates I have done white plates yeah
they never sold so they they never sold
them so they would because they would
assign that they are the work of an
architect is that they couldn't be
solved no because all the other
architects things so Michael Gray might
excel Michael Graves makes a living
of target honestly and if you should go
to Michael's I you know Michael a dear
dear friend
we're doing an oral history together
and for me it seemed very sad to see his
studio now turning out whatever it is
for a target market because according to
you that's designed not architecture and
its design of a certain sentimental the
lowest possible common denominator and
Gropius would be a design or not yeah
absolutely
mm-hm but now that we know that you
worked for him and that's why you have
every reason to be suspicious that you
might be a closet designer mess
masquerading as an architect you you
could announcing aesthetics in the name
of something obviously superior form
form mold which is not aesthetic no it
also is at certain times aesthetic but
its goal is not the aestheticization of
products I can there could be an
aesthetic argument which it could even
be crucial but that's not a deal done
either whole deal let's go back by the
way I have to tell honestly I left
architecture as I knew or whatever that
was Gropius was called precisely because
of that the reasons I'm articulating
today that there was some frustration
that all these guys were interested in
was let's make it look let's make the
things look good without any rationale
at all were just turning stuff away
there was no necessary internal logic to
anything Gropius your mentor I thought I
had reached the mountain okay director
of the school the Bauhaus right which is
the very center of this concept of
design that you're talking about
and director of the school at Harvard as
it assumes the name design and design
somebody well there's a symbolic figure
you can use for your well you could use
it too because the fact that they
changed it under Gropius to a School of
Design
therefore these words must mean
something
oh yeah yeah I think so but but so let's
say if Gropius is the kind of clear
figure for this concept of design that
you don't approve of you know you're
putting words in my mouth when you say
there's a difference I want to
articulate today that I don't want to
talk about approval or disapproval but
nevertheless when you mention what
Cornell is going to add to its
curriculum it's not it's going to it's
going to change but your head was going
like this as you said that and this is
your school to my school right so you
would be as somebody doesn't want to be
a designer you would now be again alum
of a design school and at school with
the proud history and tradition right
architecture yeah versus design which is
slippery
well Tooele freeze smooth I would argue
that when we take Colin Rowe and hungers
as two key figures both architects in
the true sense of the word for me they
both their major careers in the United
States were at Cornell I mean that's
part of and you know Paul Rudolph
started teaching there get hurt calm and
started teaching there
although journalists started I mean it
has had a history a history of
of interesting people there that who
were I consider our continues right and
so I bet if let's say if Gropius again
is our figure okay you know Luca Rozier
architectural designer architect but he
was trained to decorate the back of
watches yeah so he's trained as a
designer what is it he saw the light and
became an acting well most of us I think
are trained I think that all of my
students at Yale are being trained as
designers by the way and because the
object of our school is to turn people
into professional success which means
design being able to design for any
scale environment etc in other words the
the issue is not being turned into
ideologues or conceptualize or
theoretical people but to perform in an
environment a professional environment
that is the stated goal of the school at
Yale which is in every way a wonderful
place presumably the the no no I'm
saying is despite what I might consider
to be a mandate for a University Yale
takes that as its mandate and I would
argue that probably 95 percent of the
schools that we know take design as a
mandate right maybe calling it
architecture looks really just but I'm
just I'm just trying to I think I agree
with you but I'm just trying to cling on
to that word design go ahead Jeff let's
before we have some fun with it
to try to understand exactly because the
implication what you're saying is that
this word design and in the way you use
it is associated with an all too
seamless relationship between the work
of the designer or architect and the
market the market
yes so increasingly so so that the the
you know the thorn a chair is wasn't
just a shockingly successful mm-hmm
and you say it's not comfortable but
that doesn't mean it's not functional
when the function is to be a commodity
to move that's very presumably Michaels
teapot may or may not work really well
as a teapot in terms of the function of
T that's not the crucial it works really
really well at symbolizing a teapot in a
market at a certain price I would also
argue that - let's add another thing
about the market I think it is
patronizing to design have Michael
Graves design product for target which
is aimed at the lowest common
denominator of the words people who
can't afford very much who have no taste
necessarily it's not helping them to
develop a critical taste or a better eye
it's to make them feel better about the
world because they can buy mark Michael
Graves product at Target and I think
that's a very patronizing problem so
it's better if a city in the north of
Spain feels better about itself by
hiring you I don't see where that the
correlations well I mean
one version would say he's the good guy
because he's giving he's allowing
ordinary people that much money to feel
better about themselves that's that's
you don't think that's patronizing
particularly to dumb down work so that
it meets a certain market that I but so
too might be your project in the least I
didn't ever we I never got into this
discussion you know I'm just saying you
know you could you could say yeah yeah
you know you could say no questions
that's great simple patronizing you
could argue the same people can buy
self-esteem by buying the product yeah
but the thing is and if you my intention
is if we were to distinguish me in art
and design
I would interested in the discipline of
architecture not so much in the people
making people feel good in Galicia okay
as you know very well yeah and as you
know why I respect you a lot
is you screw it up so often in other
words you would still do the project
that gave you intellectual satisfaction
right even though you would lose the
client that's what you would which I
have volumetric scale right so I mean
it's an amazing thing that the project
is still moving in Galicia but if what
we're saying is true then the
architecture we admire doesn't so easily
flow through the market it does not know
I would think that history by the way
where's this art design I would argue
that history the history that we know
has rarely with exceptions has rarely
flung flowed through the market okay so
I mean the most successful practitioners
are not the practitioners we necessarily
study in
our history courses theory courses etc
right so in a certain sense that in this
in this particular way of understanding
the word design let's take kind of
efficiency let's let's take our famous
friend and what do we do with him
because that is really we should sit
here and put him on the table because
he's the most powerful architect since
Bernini we would all agree to that and
also to most to his creditors to yours
screws it up many times not as many not
a smooth it's not a smooth no but now is
he will history remember him as an
architect or a designer but you have to
answer the question because this is your
I am just the word design we didn't get
to meet you oh I thought we you you were
going along with it I'm just no I say to
you quite clearly I just want to get a
sense what your concept of design well
let's take full of the onsen let's put
him on the table and then you can come
back because I don't want to my I would
argue what happen your theory has to be
a designer right and Philips for the
most for you know we're saying there
there exceptions Philips time at Harvard
would be consistent with that and his
being totally unimpressed by Gropius
would not be significant to you because
he was nevertheless part of I would
argue it goes new product it goes so far
and I don't want to move Reinhold out of
his comfort zone but Ryan Hall has a
line in this book which says that the
corners of Johnson's pennzoil are
aesthetic and without saying whether
they should be aesthetic or not in other
words that Johnson ultimately he doesn't
say this but I'm I'm saying was an
Isetta sizer and I think corners are not
I think corners are both formal part of
the formal autonomy of architecture they
have been what makes architecture
different than design over history the
corners in Santa Maria del Apache the
corners at orbino the the corners at any
number of places where they are
considered as such are part of the
autonomy of architecture and so
therefore to aestheticized the corner to
me is to move out of architecture into
design okay so was he I wasn't making a
critique of its I agree with you about
Johnson aestheticizing right but here so
far everything that we've said sustains
an image of design as being as having a
sort of a smooth relationship to the
mind to whether decline whether they
whether that whether the market be
understood is the client or a function
or is global distribution or as right so
there's a kind of a sense of smoothness
and efficiency to it well that's
efficient you said efficient but it
before there's nobody more efficient
than Phillip Johnson okay that's mister
efficiency I I want to be careful that
the corners that you're playing for me
are not too tight that I can't get out
okay because you're saying that you're
not gonna put your I'm just I'm
listening to the adjective movement yeah
I don't see it as neutral alright I see
it design become somebody that one would
would not think highly off because
things are moving too directly and too
easily I want to change I want to say we
have agreed that architecture and design
are two different discourses right no I
thought we did I thought you said we
went in you said in our quote
the biggest the big question was I
interrupt you in the middle is it
architecture and design or architecture
or design I play at both so what we
don't know yet is whether architecture
is like something else baby or whether
it's both design and architecture in
some kind of relationship that's what we
do want to talk about cars they've
gotten confused right people think
they're doing architecture when they're
really doing design and the schools have
never recently said let's sort this
thing out and what we ought to try and
do is if we agree that it's both what
then and this is where I'm asking you
how would you define if there's a need
to have D and a what what is the end for
what it's worth I don't think I'm
necessarily so far away from what you're
doing it's for me the issue is always
the same right why the hell did I become
an octave why did that happen
of course people could argue that both
of us sitting here are not architects
right so never the neighbor less you use
and we got to be careful you find
yourself glued to architecture so
there's always this question well what
the hell is architecture if you develop
a concept called design that may not be
the real deal or may not be what it is
that drew you to architecture thinking
about design can help you think what the
hell is this actually to think that
interests me there you go so if if
design is associated with this kind of
efficiency and this kind of smoothness
this kind of lack of trauma just to
exaggerate okay and give away my point
then architecture what attracts it might
be to do with the lack of smoothness the
lack of the fluidity is sort of
interruption that delay the
contradiction the hesitation things are
not clear things are not you know if
there was anything and why would anybody
want that that's the real question why
did these two people want that why do we
yeah yeah in other words I constantly
ask myself why if that's the case and I
agree
with you that it in most cases it is why
would anybody want architecture by
itself without design why not you know
try and get both because well well one
theory that would come out of this is
there's no evidence that they do there's
no evidence that anybody really ever
wants architects in fact if they think
that architects of designers really just
being confused right it's correct right
so I mean if there's no evidence that
anybody wants that architecture they
really want design and they call it what
they want cuz they don't know the
difference but the interesting thing is
they do know the difference because my
clients are the people that I work with
know the difference between me and Frank
Gehry me and Richard Meier not saying
good or bad they do know the difference
and they don't want what they consider
to be the problems or the problematic
associated with what I do as opposed to
which which would translate in terms of
the discussion is they don't want
architecture they don't want
architecture which a reasonable person
in the audience might say ah yeah so
when somebody doesn't want you what they
don't want is architecture it's not that
they don't want you yeah it's a sort of
bad part I'm a creasing aware let me
just make it very clear that I'm
producing students at Yale graduates and
especially the students that collect
around the work that I'm doing it Yale
let's say our are totally unfit in a
real sense to move into society as they
understand architecture in other words
that I'm producing
miss misfits and I am more increasingly
aware of that that if only they could be
as miss fitted as you were when you left
this place they've got a chance
well I knew enough to I had a commission
I didn't tell you that part of the story
I had a big Commission at Cornell the
the thing came in at a hundred percent
over the budget in fact Mike McKenna
land John Fowler and I worked on it
together John Fowler went to worry you
know you know who they are and it was a
brutalist project you know probably
would have been the first brutalist
project in the United States and when it
came in over a hundred percent I said
screw it I'm out of here
and left walked away and went to England
so that's a the other side of the story
that I was not willing to make the
changes necessary to produce this
project you are the very figure kind of
poster child for a concept of
architecture which is the architecture
as a sort of misfit in the market in the
market right that which that which makes
the project attractive to you that which
makes it architecture is that which
makes it difficult for it to move in the
market and colleagues of yours friends
of yours don't have the same problem may
I ask isn't that true of Michael hanneke
the filmmaker
isn't it true of people who write great
literature that the market isn't set up
to take any of them in I mean we were
talking about Vout there before vogner
was a total misfit yeah but the question
here is whether whether whether I mean I
agree but the question here is whether
your own absurd pathology no I think
culture I would or is it good fabulous
mom
a good model for I'll tell you why
because the culture must survive the
marketplace and that's why Michael
hammock he makes the films he makes
that's why vogner designed for hour and
five-hour operas and they were rien C
was an eight-hour opera to begin with
they could never play it because nobody
wanted to sit for eight hours so we had
to cut it to four so I'm saying is that
culture the survival of culture
architecture is part of that survival
it's not the books you see in the
airport newsstands it's not what you see
in your local film houses so the
survival of culture depends upon you not
me
well the discourse is that alright no
but that's the thing I wouldn't you
could take you right yeah and your
pathology I don't call it a path or it's
a well that's kind of fat the logical of
you and and say what if it's like that
for every what if that's a good model
for the general relationship of
architecture and society and you're just
an extreme case which is why you obsess
all the time about the discipline of
actually saving the discipline you you
talk about the discipline of
architecture like other people talk
about trees and polar bears
hoisted Mississippi no question that's
precious little thing that's under
straight and you're the only one how
many other people are with you like you
are well that's two right I mean the
interest three okay so I mean I can
that's why they're here
so there's a little gang of people who
think that something that culture
doesn't want market does not fuse the
words is what culture needs know what
culture has been and seems to write and
the survive and its survival so the
survival it survives despite the market
culture will survive by the work of a
few people who won't deliver what
they've been
that's correct and design would be on
the name of delivery right and
architecture would be on on the name of
of not delivering and it seems we've got
several options here one is the sage
this is just a time thing that actually
we do deliver but we it's more slow in
other words it takes a while for the
market to tune in but it's no less a
product no less a commodity you could
argue that right like so-called
independent cinema mm-hmm being actually
an enormous ly successful Hollywood
bankable product so in other words the
we haven't said everyone Gardea but an
ever got a sensibility can be totally
according to a different time frame just
as efficient and I want to detach what
I'm talking about from the Almonte guard
because I would argue culture as
possible today
and then the avant-garde isn't so I
don't believe the avant-garde is always
associated with culture there are
moments where they do move together but
quick footnote okay in your opinion has
they been could they be such a thing as
an architectural everyone god yes I've
never been in it by the way because the
moment in time that I've Corbeau Mies
and those people were in an
architectural as for other painters
filmmakers there was a time in the early
20th century that was that the
conditions were mistaken ditions and
were so everyone got relative to
architecture itself or relative to
society because it seems to me we have
an option here of artha saying it's not
possible in architectural have one guy
no I would argue it was the opposite
architecture is only architecture in as
much as it is not easily swallowed no I
wouldn't argue that because there there
I would say that we could point to many
architects who were not avant-garde in
fact
Renaissance most of what we talked about
wasn't I mean the avant-gardist were
Brunelleschi and Albert II by the time
Bramante comes along we're in the high
Renaissance you know high period and
Palladio is a Mannerist is not Mannerist
is certainly not out on guard if
anything my work would be Mannerist or
late Mannerist in this Komachi sense of
the word or sense of vino I think the
great architecture is the way and I
think one of the mistakes we make in
teaching these people is that what they
should be searching for is the new which
is actually what design is about that
the market is about the search for the
new and the confusion is the new and the
avant-garde so we should be really
careful but I mean I as you know for me
yeah architectural haven't got is a
contradiction in terms
it's not possible to the to the extent
well I'm saying it to the extent that it
fits a kind of cultural image of
architecture architecture is precisely
is precisely cultures image of what it
is that every one guy's challenge so
architecture for for at a generic
cultural level is the representation of
stability in order and memory and so on
though the very things that the
avant-garde is dedicated to undermining
so to that extent at the at the public
official level that cannot be an
architectural level guide they can be
and have on God but in that moment there
have been moments and in that moment it
doesn't it will not register as
architecture in time well I think
of liqueur Busey was a radical drawing
of its time I can't think of many more
it was presented as an image yeah but
let's say stay with that one it was
present presented as an image not by
accident of efficiency right even the
presumption of that diagram is that the
walls would be produced by the rubble of
the war right so in other words it's
about the how to get the most from the
least and Buckminster Fuller terms and
so it was presented as the new ordering
system and as an image of control so it
was it was a you could say yes it's a
radical drawing yes it it became a
weapon in a wide-ranging transformation
of the way architects are producing
buildings but you can't say that that
drawing is a vanguard in the sense of
the work of heaven God artists all right
but so whose whose images whose images
had to represent the opposite had to
represent and and and so in a way you
could say the Domino drawing is the is
the is the birth of order after war
right and the everyone guard is
absolutely the continuation of the
trauma right because it's gonna come
back it's gonna come back wait because
we better come back soon rather than
later because I I would argue that the
history of culture produces at certain
moments in time ruptures in the sequence
of epistemic order paradigmatic order
and there are shifts and those shifts in
retrospect could be said to be
avant-garde in both writing in painting
and music etc when vogner shifts from
the in the third act of Siegfried I'm
sorry because I just got on full and
produces Tristan and Tristan opens in
London and they say this isn't music
you know because he's shifted from
symmetrical triads which were the
structure of the melodic structure of
the work to asymmetrical triads and
hearing the cultural hearing at the time
couldn't hear this as music and so he
was panned when it opened tristan opened
in london and yet you can look back on
it and say that was a radical shift in
the engagement of music and words and
performance and instrumentation so you
could call that avant-garde even though
people thought it was junk at the time
okay right so it we look back on things
as you can't set out to be I don't think
any any creative act
I mean Bogner was just tired of what he
was doing
decided to shift years late beethoven
and of course you know i've been last
year we talked about lateness and you
know Adorno talks about Beethoven's miss
Misa solemnity as a late work because
the it was not avant-garde not
understandable in Beethoven's over not
at a moment in time where things were
going to shift yet there was a radical
difference in his late work than in his
other work okay so but but so but let's
say bring us back to the design
architecture thing okay because of
course the total work of art of Wagner
and so on is in a very particular
relationship with total design etc in in
the copious sense for what it's worth
this would be my spin on your story I'm
inclined to accept your petition for the
for this particular description of
design this kind of architecture no I'm
just no I'm saying I accept the idea
that that design that design could be
seen as the ambition for a sort of
smooth relationship relative to program
market function and aesthetics and a six
as as part of that and implied in that
is a kind of technocratic sense of
design which is why post design was also
huge word for back mr. Faure and yeah
and the other I would hate to say
technocratic because that's putting a
pejorative on it if you're in that field
it's all good if you're gonna argue that
which would make a school of design yeah
that would make a school of design a
school that says to society we can
design anything tell us what you want
and we can do it we're talking about and
we can distinguish between a good design
and a bad design because it'll be which
one is smoother more efficient more
programming in other words it can be
perfected so tell me if that if it's a
kind of industrialization of what of
architecture so let me ask you a
question if that if we accept that as a
definition and we accept that there's a
difference and we're gonna put my more
modest disciplinary distinction between
architecture and design why is it that
we don't make those distinctions in the
schools that we teach it I can't see one
school that I would say stands for
something different than compliance I
think to answer that question which I'd
love to give it a shot it it seems we
yeah we for a while so we gain for a day
we still have to zoom in on we have to
zoom in on the design architectural idea
but nobody we've got the design side
right kind of figured out which the
world will be very grateful for but the
the
the architecture part not right right
and the way I would would for what it's
worth say it is the the reason that I
could that that that thing which draws
us to architecture and to which I
believe all architects are drawn is has
exactly to do with a break in that
smoothness that we've been talking about
let's argue it from fundamentals if if
people even want to come up with some
sort of uber basic description of
architecture they tend to get back to
the question of shelter and with shelter
they get back to the body and the body
and place and all that stuff right but
even that most primitive sense that
whatever architecture is it's something
to do with shelter even if it's not
shelter itself but the lasing
emplacement and the body and so on but
as you know my position would be
architecture does not shelter anything
in fact shelter is an idea right and
architecture does not shelter the human
body the human body does not exist as
such without this idea of shelter
shelter is is the beginning of producing
an image of that thing called the body
right so architects in that sense don't
design for bodies they design by this
and every architect here is associated
with their work a kind of image of what
body is those that want to kind of more
easily tie architecture to this sort of
smooth relationship with culture and
therefore the cultural demand for order
security control and so on will
endlessly in public identify
architecture with the stability and
certainty of the human body of place
phenomenology was it that way to say
that right
our analogy was the way to say it and
all of that suggested that you could
that modernity modernity and that from
that point of view is perceived of as a
form of assault and even a kind of
military assault because in its a in its
origin on this precious party but no
longer well yeah okay but so so
modernity is seen of as a form of
assault and therefore the therefore what
the architect does is try to modulate
the sensual experience of space in such
a way that produces a delay or at least
a critique if not a critique a delay a
hesitation or form of installation from
all of this industrial capacity and so
on so from that point of view I people
who are trying to tie architecture to
images of certainty and stability have a
kind of hypothetical primordial
experience between the body and space
around which everything else is either
chaotic or authentic or not authentic
right but it seems to me that the body
is polymorphous absurd unknowable
perforated confusing and and multiple so
in fact the role of architecture of the
role of shelter even staying at this
primitive level as opposed design as a
yeah we haven't even got there yet is
actually a disavowal of all of that
traumatic stuff but who teaches that the
that I mean what you just outlined is
the basis of a curriculum for a graduate
school of architecture I would subscribe
to yeah who teaches that we're gonna get
dumped there I would argue there's two
questions I'm saying that your answer
the first has to be no one does teach
that by the way honestly
- the question is why not well I think
the answer is everyone does but you've
got you've got here a you've got a split
in the discipline and and that's why
it's not architecture or design design
because active itself is fundamentally
split by the fact that from my point of
view as architects we are drawn to what
is unknown and unknowable about
buildings for us buildings are weird
therefore we work with them love them
spend our lives with them because they
fascinate us they don't fascinate
culture culture has a pretty clear
understanding of what a building is
meant to do so as a discipline
architects are called on to produce
images of certainty and security and
stability which help stabilize in
particular flows in the market etc and
if you're willing to just deliver that
then fine you deliver it and you become
one of these people that have moved into
what you call the world of design but in
so doing what you cannot tell your
clients is ever you don't know what the
hell a building is and the whole reason
you're in this in the first place is
that you find buildings fundamentally
mysterious so the discipline is divided
between a kind of private life of
architects who secretly find every
building mysterious and destabilizing
and know perfectly that they're not
designing for a body but are producing a
kind of protective image of what might
be a possible body classical ArcheAge
the most obvious example is that
supposedly based on how come how come
then this this distinction this split
first of all is not an equal split
because it's ninety ten as far as I
could see well because we're training
for the these are where all these
students are in professional school
they're getting a professional degree
right it's like a business school or law
school med school architecture schools
are this isn't a humanist discipline
so they're here supposedly to to be part
of the 90/10 right but if if the
cultural purpose I mean this is a
incredibly gross Syrio type right but if
they if the major cultural mechanism for
architecture the reason that so much
money is sometimes put into it not often
but sometimes put into it is for it to
to as it were disavow the unknown and
the uncertain restaurant and produce
images of stability uncertainty that
allow the rest of cultural life to be a
bit weird weirdness and buildings is the
last thing that we will tolerate right
the the the building is that which
actually defines what weirdness might be
its the buildings are the non-weird
there's sort of touchstones right if
that's the case and on the other hand
the craft of the architect is that this
is a sort of a fiction this this is a
kind of theatrics and architects are the
experts in that theatrics like any other
performance artists you have a choice
between you can perform it you can
produce the image of certainty for your
client on time and on budget or you can
say by the way this is fiction this is
theater
yeah the moment you say that you lose
the job that's architects who are
foolish enough to think that what's most
exciting about architecture is it's
weird
yeah like yourself lose the job right
right so then at us so you're an extreme
case let's say I don't think you know
looser jobs anymore which either means
you're no longer interesting or that
you've found a kind of candy way of
bringing the uncertainty up and into the
surface so you deliver both and that's
what I mean by divided you deliver both
the product that's being asked for but
it's got a little weirdness in it
and because there's quite a lot of
weirdness in your stuff you don't get
that much work but you get a lot of work
and your friends that don't deliver any
weirdness at all right get a ton
right that's it and it here's the thing
and everybody knows the difference they
can smell weirdness as opposed to non
witness by the way a the most
unenlightened people the the issue is
how is it possible then because I would
argue I've always think it's quite
extraordinary that I have a 500 million
euro Commission you know for the stadium
for 400 million
I mean you know I think it's quite
extraordinary that I must have gotten
very canny or I was very disabled but I
think what happens and this is I don't
think it son you need I think it takes a
long time to develop strategies to be
able to do both I think that I waited
until I was 50 before I really went into
practicing other than in houses etc with
real building larger scale buildings and
you you think about things I mean all
the architects that I consider in this
Pantheon all wrote and and put out their
treatises before whether it's venturi or
koolhaas Palladio is one of the ones
that didn't he wrote at the end but
quick questions about it if if the real
if from the from cultures point of
view some sort of abject scenes of
culture the real power and value of
architecture is that it can kind of
manifest stability security and order no
I don't think that is that but I think
if this is the reverse but if there is
this yeah call for the architect to
represent these things the call for
architecture comes because architectures
meant to be able to represent that
without any words it just is strong
secure and stable so why do you guys do
all this writing if it does not
you to stand there and explain itself
perfectly well you could argue at Tony
viddler has made this really beautiful
argument between Rossi and sterling for
the news this darling show that's coming
up
that's sterling that Rossi was only able
to articulate this dissonance this
critique in his writing whereas sterling
couldn't write but his buildings were
all about articulating that dissonance
in building so some architects are able
to do what sterling did and some are
able to do what Rossi did but if you
took away the writing the whole thing
collapses agreed well if you took away
what sterling was doing the whole thing
no but what I'm saying is that those
those Arctic's who don't write so much
couldn't do their thing without the
others that do well you can't you can't
imagine architecture without writing
that's correct you know and of course
you you're not a good witness to that
you're a writer so you like the wrong
person to talk to but nevertheless if we
agree that that but the very fact that
our discipline depends on writing is
already a kind of confession that
objects don't simply stand there and do
what culture asked them to do so it's
the it's or it's the very it's the
beginning of conceding that we might
want the object to do these things but
it's a desire right which is the
beginning of saying we don't really know
what objects are I want to go to a case
in point okay which I discovered just in
my first trip to Moscow was Stalin's
Seven Sisters right couldn't be examples
of a more bureaucratic totalitarian
image-making
there's no theory necessary to see these
buildings is what they were in Moscow
there was even going to be an eighth one
that never got finished
and they were see from going to be the
palace of the Soviets which was going to
be the granddaddy of all of these said
fact they were called sisters it's
interesting there's no writing necessary
for that and they're not great
architecture but they certainly do
something that architecture does in the
city well yeah I think I'm not trying to
say that I'm not I'm not saying that
because having said that and they don't
depend on write without writing there is
no yeah there is no architecture that
doesn't mean that objects don't have
force okay so it's just saying that the
force play it's just that you can't
think of the force of the object without
entering into a discourse there was a
lot of discourse around those I think
really beautiful towers designs by a guy
who worked on the Empire State Building
so again the hard part of American
capital of the communist depended on the
same they came out of the same same spec
spec the energy the energy for that
started with the Empire State Building
with Stalin got the idea for this from
the Empire State Building but
celebrities like has a great argument
about those very buildings where he says
that's the perfect demonstration there I
mean you housing it as how to represent
how to represent an egalitarian society
you represent an eagle and Surrey
society with a series of representations
of high rank right his argument which is
of course relates to what I'm saying in
the sense that I think if if the real
issues of one there's no writing
necessary but are they architecture and
I think that's where we might come apart
because I would argue that in terms of
the discipline that you want to Reinhold
wants us to stop and ask for no we just
we would just get more democratic but
know we can we can stop but I mean I
think we this is where you and I might
apart because there's something quite
amazing about those buildings but if you
were to study them
architectural II in terms of the
discipline they're quite trivial and so
therefore I would say the World Trade
Center for example Yamasaki towers were
quite trivial yet there's something
really obviously very important about
them what you just chose I you chose two
terrible examples either because either
because I'm in love with those two you
know which just demonstrates that I
don't like the things that you like no
no no misaki's Towers were was a work
work unmatched by the middle and even
lower echelon of our field which
includes you yeah they were we are not
sitting at the same table and what we've
managed to do in an hour
is get them all to believe that we're on
the same page and the thing that would
be really interesting and we'll get
there in eight nine or ten is what what
is that difference because there is a
gap and I'm understand that I can't
explain it necessarily I know that you
love those building likes the building
the cynic one on of buildings and yet
neither of those which I acknowledge as
signposts or symbols or whatever neither
of them represent what I considered to
be architecture could sit about for the
best design yes especially the Gropius
was yes and therefore that's where I
think Philip was a great whatever
pooh-bah but will history remember
his work as architecture in other words
the and I would point to the AT&T
building is one of the real you know
problematic buildings in his serve I
mean well he had I mean 70 percent of
his work was was I mean I mean I think
it would be really interesting to see
how history treats Philip and I think
also don't see I don't think that's
gonna be that interesting because if you
if if anything we said today made any
sense it's it's that architecture is a
question right not an answer so so and
this gets a little bit getting back to
your question about architecture schools
if at some level anyway architects are
supposed to do on the side of of clarity
and rip and certainty and even you could
argue as a discipline architects are
called on to explain their work in a way
that's not true of any other discipline
so there's a meant to be a sort of
clarity and explain ability in
architecture on the one side on the one
side and on the other side the reason
any any of us ever got into this game
was because of the opposite that
opposite objects seem to be endlessly
infinitely new pleasurably if on the one
hand we're we're men we are we're in a
public discourse which is about a
clarity and explanations and so on but
we're also in a private discourse which
is about objects are super fascinating
to us because they're unclear that means
every architect is constantly thinking
about that line between the love of what
the object the love of not knowing what
the object is and being called on to say
publicly what they are schools then
could and clearly that we don't know
what they are is on the side of what the
hell is architecture which is on the
side of research which the side of
exploration of experimentation so
schools like this one are very big on
that side what the hell is the object
where the hell is
going in as much as a professional
school you have to talk about this line
right now you could say a school of
design it's gone too far across the line
and they don't they've left this dilemma
behind other words certainly gets left
behind schools that position themselves
as laboratory schools of which this is
one and I'm not sure if there's a second
right in that sense are trying to
maximize maximize the time spent on the
private side of the discourse versus
that public side I would argue I'm not
trying to take anything away from your
description of this school I would argue
that I would find it hard to make that
distinction between Princeton Harvard
Yale Columbia etc I would really
students have no problem I'm a big fan
of very schools I'm a big fan of schools
I can give you my list of war I think
Princeton Yale haven't it's on a
terrific schools
what's great actually about the u.s. in
terms of architectural education is
these profound differences between those
schools there are profound differences
but I'm not certain that the students
the ones that you are certain are yeah
they could articulate the difference
yeah they know and if they don't do we
care about them oh yeah damn well we
care about but I think we should start
talking yeah with them but I I I'm not
as convinced that you are i I think that
we have not made a very I have not made
and it's a really difficult thing that's
why I'm doing a seminar on it to
articulate what the hell Peter do you
mean by architecture that's different
than the difference that mark Wigley
means between architecture and design
right I find that really in the realm of
mysticism well I think architecture is a
reflection on the status of the object
which can mean in this context
it's a reflection of our design yeah
right so so so the the it's got
questioning an exploration and a placing
and doubt of and a framing and enjoying
of that question Ryan which means an
expression like architectural design was
even the name of a magazine if remember
rightly is some sort of contradiction in
terms or some sort of weird expression
the very magazine in which in right you
moralist published your first article
under kenneth right which wasn't towards
an understanding of form 63
so you leave Columbia is an idiot you
can't speak French so you go to London
where they speak almost American and and
then you find yourself in Cambridge yeah
and soon you're making a path straight
up towards a PhD I'm very short very
very quickly you're publishing a text on
form right but in the background is not
willing to hang around to deal with a
professional environment in which you
over the budget right so there's a sort
of a walking away from the profession
and its problems deep deep into the
university and I never got back and a
theorizing of this thing called form
right which is not designed right for
you but that would form was big word for
these for your enemies right yeah
Bauhaus right so anyway we're just
passing the time will you make a
question questions there should be lots
of questions because I have lots of them
for you guys
well let me answer your question Frank
gave a lecture this spring at Yale
because I don't want to talk about
Bilbao necessarily and he showed 30 of
my latest buildings in the last six
months okay and I turned to my Dean and
I said how do you know which one is a
good one or what I really meant how do i
how do you know which one is
architecture or which one is critical or
which one is massagin ated or whatever
because we had seen one point one point
point point point point thank you
and my Dean turned back to me and he
said that's not the point and there is
the answer that I would give you whether
Frank Gehry's work is what we're talking
about or not for the work is not the
point that's not the point of the work
and I hope that is a clear answer
and if you need a clearer answer
professor Kenneth Frampton who is
professor in residence here would give
you a much clearer answer
I can't say that because the irreparable
rift already exists been papered over
and for the last 50 years so it's not
gonna get any better or worse it exists
but I don't think that necessarily means
that Frank's work is I think Frank's
work is fabulous all right question is
is it about architecture and that's
really some of the buildings are some
are yeah I I think I mean my way of
answering the same question would be to
say that if if if architecture is the is
the endless trying to figure out what
the hell objects iron can be and part of
that is participating in in allowing
societies to try to communicate their
highest aspirations because generally
architects are on the optimism side of
the fence
it's not that any one object is ever
more architectural than another but at
any one time there can be arguments
about one object being or not so
according to the particular framework
that Peters using the fact that he can't
differentiate between 30 objects makes
it means that it's not architecture but
if we were talking about Andy Warhol we
might say that's the charm of the whole
thing and that's what makes it critical
makes it critical so there's nothing
inherently critical or non-critical
architectural non architectural about
repetition I mean it could be argued
that in other words but Frank isn't
doing repetition to be critical right
that's what the difference so in terms
of Peters operational definition of
architecture that works just not going
to register
historically that will change Peters own
view may change Ryan he may turn around
and say that just was the golden moment
of Franco's last those particular six
months of 2010 try me next I think it's
a fair question though and Frank is is a
is on the cusp of that in other words
the real issue among the inner circles
let's say is is the work part or is it
architecture and a lot of people who are
let's say painters and sculptors that
both of us know would say it ain't great
part okay and and that's in other words
that's the real issue in other words
Michael Graves also is a person that
falls on that line who does a lot of
painting and Richard Meier does a lot of
sculpture and sculptors and painters
I think wouldn't think that their
production and their tendency toward
that kind of production is is what they
would consider in their disciplines of
great work but you can surely imagine a
PhD student in 15 years analyzing
Frank's relationship to the market and
observing that he in a somewhat
brilliant way managed to turn large
cultural buildings to give them the same
status as teapots or whatever in in a
kind of very canny understanding of how
or what architecture can represent and
what it can do and see that even as a
kind of as one of the most interesting
and worth remembering features of this
moment but just as easily in in 15 years
of whatever there could be zero
discussion about that name I mean this
is really I wouldn't I would I would say
no I would say that that moment the
Bilbao effect is always going to be a
cultural phenomenon that we that PhD
students in 15 years will be analyzing
because for our free we're obviously the
same generation for our generation
Bilborough is an effect but I think you
could imagine that in 20 years that's
not even considered an effect it's just
that I can't think ahead 20 no but you
can you
consider that we have another question
yeah yeah you spoke about the disconnect
between what architects are interested
in and what architecture art intends to
represent when built so then he's
building it all I mean if you're an
architect at the true architect why
would you build it all then well I'll
tell you what Manfredo Tafari who I
would consider a real critic historian
their addition one of the important ones
of the last century said to me Peter if
you don't build nobody will be
interested in your ideas and I think
ultimately the test of any discourse is
the performance of that discourse vogner
can write operas if you don't perform
them it doesn't mean anything you can
write music and let if nobody reads the
literature listens to the music it
doesn't matter so I would ultimately
argue that an architect must must
perform in some way and part of that
performance is building so then would
you say the purity isn't possible that
building inherently involves compromise
no I think building any anything
involves compromise I mean publishing
you know the fact that you write a tower
opera and it can't be performed because
nobody wants to sit through it nobody
wants to sit through a 15 hour film
either ultimately there are restrictions
that to make to performance of any
performance whether it's a novel I mean
you can't have a 5,000 page novel nobody
wants to carry it around etc so I would
argue all performance in VII is not pure
it's not original
and yet it is ultimately original
because it's always a one-off thing so
Wagner argued that the only importance
of his work was the performing of it
that it had to be performed a lot of
people would argue that the composers
and conductors argue that you that they
hear the music better when it's not
performed in its more original state so
performance is not original whether a
building or whatever performance is
something other than if the issue of
originality is which is come into
question then I I don't worry about the
question of originality I think it's a a
red herring so I think you have to
perform and you have to build yeah I
mean just a variation it
I mean firstly to say that the there's a
difference between what what what draws
architects towards the object and what
the architect is asked to do this is
such a sort of non impressive thing to
observe right
it's like saying there's got to be a
difference between what painters are
really thinking about when they're
painting and it's and delivering
paintings to collectors and so on it's
it's it it's usually something else
maybe every now and then there's a so
what impresses me is that anybody would
be surprised by that observation and and
that surprised that maybe there's a big
gap between what architects are thinking
about when they produce the work and
what it is that they call on to say the
workers in public for anybody to be
surprised by that is one more sign of
the special status that given to
architectural representations in our
society that seem to be a more obscene
problem should be thinking about what
they're supposed to be thinking about
but if you listen to your question a
performance could only be understood as
compromised if there's a theory right
and if we've said there's no
architecture without theory
yes by definition one way to answer your
question is all buildings are
compromised but compromise is not
understood as a negative it's it's in
relationship to a to a theoretical
aspiration it would be read as
compromise but all theory is equally
compromised and can be understood as
compromise
relative to objects one other thing all
of you whether you become designers or
architects and you will become mostly
designers will realize that clients do
not come around and present you with
theoretical opposite opportunities to
build buildings that a spouse or gender
theory ninety percent of the work that
comes out of our office has no
theoretical consonance or relevance at
all to what we do the opportunities for
theory or theoretical exploration in
practice our very very few to be given
an opportunity and most of the times
they occur in competitions we're doing a
competition right now in Italy which
we're not going to win because we're
breaking the rules but we're breaking
the rules in order to express a certain
theoretical value let's say in the
competition and the competition is
explicitly set up so that there is no
theoretical value the same was we did a
competition a few years ago the same
thing happened we broke the rules we
were ruled out I'd rather break the
rules in a competition to do something
relevant to what I consider to be
architecture then just follow the rules
because if you most most Commission's
are follow the rules follow the bouncing
ball etcetera
not set up we want a great piece of
architecture and that's what design is
is set up to produce designers but if
they had a kind of a rule that said an
architect's only an architect if they
build you'd have to take a hell of a lot
of books out of every library you just
be a lot of people that up to this point
where thought of as architects as the
most influential people you know and
they've got to go according to that rule
so it makes no sense it makes no sense
maybe one architect who's written a book
that we think about that hasn't built as
architects not historians theoreticians
critics made me one architectural book
that's in the library that comes from
somebody that never built well I think
the question would have to be are
slightly differently okay it would be
find and find an architect who may have
done a building but that building in no
way contributed to their status in our
case for example you could take somebody
who famously resisted building like
Cedric price and you could say ah but he
did the Avery but do you really think
that the Avery that he did with Lord
Snowdon is a requirement as a kind of
license for him to be to have the
influence of a socially but not you know
I mean prices I have as I do with some
of your choices for a constant price I
have problems with those guys
all right but I mean you know I think
the Avery is a great thing but I don't
think I I don't think it's it's what
allows us what allows him to be
influential you know well let's ask the
question the Potteries think though yeah
is a really important project does it
matter that it wasn't
see I would argue in my mind it was good
well but then we're on the same team
again right I mean the the pottery sink
belt didn't need to be built to be
important yeah according to the theory
that you have to build in order to be an
Arctic centric crisis vulnerable not
just because he hardly built but he
theorized the importance of not building
right I don't think he theorized that
well I give him a lot he didn't theorize
the importance of he said the single
most greatest responsibility an
architect is to be ready to say I'm not
gonna do it he would and there was an
act of British Parliament
this will allow him not to be excluded
from the architects for saying that
because that was heretical against the
discipline of architecture right and he
found his famous example was a couple
comes to you for a house and instead of
doing the house for them you should
recommend that they get divorced because
the house is trying to produce an image
of that which is fallen apart right he
was threatened with legal action for
that and and because he had friends in
Parliament so in other words say he's a
very good example of somebody who even
made not building the architectural
statement I don't think the exception to
the rule necessarily disproves the rule
of the question he was asking I think
it's important for most people who want
to be architecture to overcome design
and this restrictions of design in order
to perform if we had no performance but
by your argument that the non
performance because designed wouldn't
permit it the non performance of what
we're talking about architecture we
wouldn't know what architecture was as
opposed to design no because you're
twisting the argument the to say that
you don't need to make a building to be
Anarkali doesn't mean nobody needs to
build
you were hinting it's just to say to
furry was wrong and the fact that you've
done buildings hasn't made the cardboard
house projects house ten etc more
powerful in the field
in fact there's every reason to think
that the fact that your client didn't
come through on house ten and Philip
Johnson took pity on you and gave you
some cash
and so you could develop a little bit
more discourse you can argue that not
only is house ten in the book form
better than it ever could have been in
Rio in reality number one and number two
the frustration you felt at not being
able to build this thing at the end of
that sequence right was perhaps much
more productive and ultimately
influential in the field in shaping you
as an intellectual much more than the
fact that you may have made some
buildings well that's because you were
traumatized so you look at your like the
the last person in the universe who
should be saying if you don't build
you're not enacting because every if you
don't build you're suffered trauma every
every Oba theoretical architect who
nobody ever thought would build every
one of those who finally does build
always says you know what you've always
got a built there was earlier some
discomfort about the idea of a
architectural avant-garde but Peter
Eisenman your definition or a
distinction between architecture and
design reminded me somewhat of Clemente
Greenberg's distinction between
avant-garde and kitsch which was based
on medium specificity and I was thinking
if architecture perhaps architectures
sir guard against the market or against
design is its status as a discipline in
the classical sense with the sort of own
rules and boundaries or at least a stake
in boundaries that design sort of
threatens because design is has this
sort of seamless relationship with the
market
so I was wondering if maybe this shift
in school from architecture school
schools of architecture to schools of
design that you were wondering about
might be attributable to something or
symptomatic of something as obvious as
for lack of a better word the neoliberal
ization of Education of higher education
the what the neoliberal ization of
education where universities and
education are having more and more
pressure to conform to market demands
well that's certainly I would argue why
Cornell is thinking of changing as
precisely what I've written against that
notion is that they are needing to reply
to market demands and they believe that
changing to college of design will be
one step toward helping ameliorate that
problem they think that I it's not a
difficult question for me but I need to
ask you a question because you've I've
noticed it three times taking notes on
it why you switch languages in the
particular terminology uber theoretical
why is that a I mean could we ask that
question just just before we guys a
footnote to our discussion because it's
not your native life you don't even
pronounce it correctly yeah
and so why the hell what does that meant
to mean to these people well they did
I'm not sure it's an exciting answer but
I think it's going to be for me if you
give us a a real one well you know from
my point of view every architects of
theorists the indication of what we're
saying is that the architect is an
intellectual right then an architecture
thinks about the meaning of objects and
the relationship of objects of society
so what we do is think so it's very when
we get to the in it and we've got a
we've got a privileged relationship to
the question of thinking because it just
happens that architecture is used by
society as a kind of image of thought in
action right so not only do we think a
lot about architecture think about the
meaning of objects but actually we are
supposed to demonstrate in public how
objects can articulate ideas like
aspirations and so on so we sort of
think about thinking so we're very much
theorists but that but one doesn't have
to build I mean that's one explanation
of why one doesn't have to build but
also the reverse is true that there what
the person who builds and hardly ever
talks is no less theoretical for that
reason a Jim sterling right
so by uber theoretical I mean it's I
mean an Arctic says I'm a theorist I'm a
theorist which they're not more
theoretical they're just branding
themselves yes nobody nobody has more
nobody to watch the us-brazil I mean you
didn't watch us Brazil come on they're
not a man of this tree you don't when
the men on the street even to have a
Michael Graves teapot I mean what a man
on the street is well that's true yeah
you know a community where is one of the
77,000 how is the stadium you should
have called me I was looking for
somebody to go anyway so what am i when
I went on to the question of
radical uber theoretical means somebody
says hey hey I'm theoretical which is
which is not a more theoretical act and
by the way the reverse is true somebody
who says there's too much theory around
I don't want theory that's a theory
that's a theory so the anti theory
theory which is by the way all the rage
actually the anti series theory yeah
it's generally in the ascent and every
now and then has a dip down yeah and the
dip down people speak of the rise of
theory in the eighties I'm coming to
think now that it was the just a dip in
ante theory all right but I want to say
I think that I think your in your
analysis is good and an inaccurate and I
think that the the kind of Kitsch
avantgarde argument of Greenman so that
that's mapping on reasonably well to
this design and actually if you it's
it's it's written that way in the
greenberg argument but also your final
conclusion i think is totally super
accurate but i wouldn't necessarily
describe the university or any
universities as being under pressure to
near liberals I mean University is
actually doing what they want to do in
the case of Cornell this is they're not
being forced to adopt this relationship
they're seeking that relationship I
think the question and I don't see
virtue on either side by the way I don't
I think a university that says that it
is in a difficult and compromised
relationship to to it's outside that's
not necessarily
kind of more ethically or
philosophically more sophisticated
position than a university that says we
will refuse to be contaminated by the
outside it seems to me an intelligent
University and universities should be
intelligent right thinking about that so
a lot a lot of what you can find
universities doing is actually I gotta
finish this Institute two important
universities are not are are and have
always been an integral part of that
so-called outside world University is
part of that system it's it's it's
designed to be that way students who
choose to come to an Ivy League or non
Ivy League
enter through the walls are there's a
theatrics to this what you're saying is
I leave behind the market in order to be
isolated from market forces in order to
think but why so that when I go back
into the market I don't go out as an
idiot right so basically the mechanism
of university is to create a withdrawal
from the market in order to engage more
intelligently with the market so the
withdrawal is in the name of the market
it's not actually a kind of withdrawal
which is why somebody who graduates from
a school as an idiot can have the most
important contribution to make to that
world to which they know at first don't
fit right so so the problem would be the
problem I would have is not with it with
the school that is in a kind of hyper
fluid relationship to the market
commodities and all of that but if it's
kind of absolutely seamless like if
there is ZERO rippling going on between
the moment of reflection and the moment
of action that seems to me a total waste
of resources because then essentially
there wouldn't there wouldn't be any
difference between the inside of the
university and and its outside so why
good students spend all this money to be
where you were in the first place so
it's our school school has to create and
endlessly modify the potential
relationships between the architect and
the market and schools have to be
laboratories for theories about what
possible new relationships are there and
students have to be better than the
schools that they're in and have to
defeat the school and demonstrate that
the school is not that interesting which
means schools have to be as interesting
as they can in order that it's easier
for the students to then defeat the
school and create new models new species
of the architect so my problem would be
only with schools that think they know
what an architect is because that seems
to me the end of the discussion and the
end of what is beautiful about the
activities at leas don't know what they
don't know where they I don't know who
they are and that's their strength 50
years 50 years and he still doesn't know
who he is at Cornell they are thinking
of of cutting the conflict apart okay
that is being done because they as they
perceive the world
there ain't no market for people other
than other schools of complet out there
where it's one of the first programs in
conflict where demand went dairy that
went when they came to the United States
was Cornell so it has a tradition there
they're thinking of cutting it all right
and I would argue that architecture is
in the same kind of danger that complet
is in and what he's suggesting is
absolutely correct that we have to be
vigilant because complet even if it has
no business on the market is an
important discourse especially in an Ivy
League institution and what's
interesting about I'm not sure about
that all right what's interesting about
Cornell and what I've tried to argue
with there AG school etc the people go
to Cornell to the AG school because it
is Cornell and Ivy League if you lose
what makes Cornell Ivy League that is
complet because they don't have that
at Ohio State or Michigan State or other
big AG schools you no longer are in in
in a sense within the Ivy League because
you don't have those things that
distinguish the Ivy League schools from
the big Midwestern state universities
and I think there is a reason to make
that distinction and that what I've said
to the Dean of the agriculture school to
Cornell is you've got to support keeping
complet here because it's what sustains
your program as different from Ohio
State and Michigan State and if you
don't realize that lose complet and
you'll see what happens right but then
but what you're saying is kind of keep
the lost leader complet because overall
it contributes to action yeah right
right architecture right as a lost
leader right by the way but that
accredit place but that argument
keep the lost leader to maintain the
overall brand is a market argument so in
other words yes it's not like the market
is saying don't have any use for complet
so let's get rid of it so evil market is
doing that it's the market argument that
will keep it there that's right so it
keeps their act when they want to when
they want to get rid of the architecture
school at Cambridge University they did
will you for or against it I was totally
against you wanted to keep the school
absolutely and and and what
contributions had the school been making
to the field zero in how many decades
zero completely made any was important
that a major one of the Oxford
universities have architecture so this
man is such a rabid union representative
of the virtue of architecture that he
will defend at one of the premier
research universities in the world
should maintain a school of architecture
even if that school has never ever
contributed anything to the field of
architecture but he's so much less needs
architecture to be a here right so I
think there is a counter-argument that
says that of course they probably are
very silly decisions being made at
Cornell I mean not disagree with you but
hypothetically allowing architecture to
come and go in the university spectrum
would be intellectually more interesting
than imagining and that it will always
be there I think there's there's every
reason to think perhaps architecture is
like newspapers and very very very
quickly architecture schools will no
longer really have what an intelligent
role to play in the universe one arc now
you see why not all right wait what
architecture school has ever flourished
under an engineering school there are a
lot of architecture schools that are
within engineering schools and they make
more money being there they're well
funded under them but they they don't
produce the kinds of things that an
independent architecture school does so
I would argue there is plenty of history
to suggest that when you Barack
bureaucratize a discipline in other
words move it into a place where it
doesn't belong like out of Arts and
Science out of the humanities etc give
an example at Rutgers NJIT is a
bureaucratization of taking certain
disciplines out of Rutgers University
like architecture and putting them in an
engineering context NJIT has never
flourished right and architecture has
never flourished at Rutgers because yeah
but you could shoot architecture or put
it in an engineering school and I would
rather be shot I agree but right I
refuse to sign the letter saying we
should keep the School of Architecture
Cambridge why because at least you want
at least at some point
no no it's finally one thing to come the
only thing that ever came out of
Cambridge actually came from that other
that lately my other thing that was off
to one side all right but if let me take
say to the other way and this is we're
just basically trying to erase me from
the ubermensch category back at the
Columbia category if if what's exciting
about architects and I like architects
right
thank you right more or less as a
species as a species we are addicted to
the questions about objects right yeah
that's the case it's the sort of
instability and uncertainty about what
in the end is the figure of the
architect is kind of crucial to it's
crucial to the whole thing but every
statement by Anarkali every drawing
every class comes up the question what
is accurate we've spent two hours trying
to say what we think about it so we're
not done right but if if we are serious
about what we're saying that the
fragility of the concept of architecture
the fragility of it is the deep beauty
of it for us
no matter that society wants
architecture to be everything except
fragile but if the fragility of even the
most solid object is for us the most
precious thing then we let the team down
when we say no matter what happens in
the universe there should always be a
School of Architecture oh no I think cuz
then the fragility is gone we're saying
like it's not that fragile it's just
architectures is that exactly proves its
fragility when it can't do anything and
it still needs to be there all right
that's good that's good trick we got a
guy thanks for putting up with us thank
you